Speaker 1: One other clip I want to look at
related to the Supreme Court leaker. So we
had a more serious discussion a few minutes
ago in the context of what Tulsi Gabbard said
about the kind of equal likelihood,
based on what we know right now,
that the leaker might have been someone
on the left who supports abortion rights
or someone on the right who's against abortion
rights. We just don't know one way or the other.
But now I want to play for you a clip from
Newsmax where the host grant stink field,
with absolutely no evidence whatsoever, speculates
that it might be the not yet on the court but
confirmed Justice Caitlin G. Brown Jackson who
leaked the draft. Now, there's no evidence of
that. She's also not on the court. And how she
would have access to the draft, I don't know.
But here's Grant Stink Fields perspective.
Speaker 3: We're not telling them what
they can do to their bodies, though. We're
telling them what they can't do to a baby,
a precious life. And speaking of college.
Speaker 5: Brown Jackson, who you just saw there,
I find it suspect.
Speaker 3: That the first
leak coming out of the Supreme Court.
Speaker 5: In history comes shortly
after Judge Jackson is confirmed.
Speaker 3: I want to know if her law clerks,
who I am sure have already been hired.
Speaker 5: Possibly even working at
the high court already before her
swearing in, have access to these
draft decisions. She would be my first suspect.
Speaker 3: When it comes to the leak because.
Speaker 5: Caitlin Jay Brown.
Speaker 1: By the way, Katon Jay,
they just can't get it right.
Speaker 5: Jackson is a radical
left wing activist, more
radical than any other justice
in the history of the Supreme Court.
Speaker 1: I think what he means is as qualified
as any other justice on the Supreme Court. So we
don't know who it was. This is total speculation.
It might have been someone on the left. It might
have been someone on the right. We know why each
side might have motivations to leak this. But
Catanese, Brown, Jackson is not on the court.
There is no evidence that I was able to find that
her forthcoming clerks are already at the Supreme
Court with access to documents. There's just
no evidence of this whatsoever. And understand,
I don't know if this hypothesis is going to
pick up steam, but the way that it will work is
Newsmax will float it without evidence, and then
people on Twitter will talk about it. And then
Tucker will say there are many people saying it
might have been Caitlin Gee, Brown Jackson. It's
what he did with the vaccines, remember? Oh, it
might. There are people saying tens of thousands
of people died from the COVID vaccines. I'm not
saying that, but there are people saying that.
And then all of a sudden it's on Fox News at
night. And then the next day, Fox News, the hard
news program, say Tucker Carlson last night said
that and that's how it gets into the news cycle.
So we'll see what kind of life this hypothesis
about Catanese, Brown, Jackson being the leaker
gets. I hope that it's not much, but there
is absolutely no evidence and it violates
a absolute and complete instinct where she's not
even working there. There's no reason to think her
clerks are there. There's no reason to think that
TAJAI Brown Jackson has anything to do with this.